MALE SPEAKER: It's time now to
get your game on, with EA and
Strike Fortress, a game designed
to be used in the
Chrome browser.
We're joined by Daniel from EA
to talk us through this.
Red versus Blue.
We're in the middle
of a game here.
Walk us through the action.
DANIEL: That's right.
We've got two guys here
who are playing.
This is Blue Team.
And it's totally in the
Chrome browser.
We're using a JavaScript and
Web GL based engine written
from scratch.
And they're communicating over
WebSockets in a client server
architecture, just like you
might play in any other
multi-player game.
So, just using all HTML5
technologies in Chrome.
So that is cool in
and of itself.
But you've got a tablet
in your hand--
DANIEL: That's right.
MALE SPEAKER: --to show us
how you can actually
play God in this game.
Let's shift over to the third
screen here to talk about it.
DANIEL: So one of the dreams of
this kind of experience is
building a technology that
can be experienced
wherever you are.
So when these guys are playing
on their desktops, playing at
home, or playing on their TVs,
in kind of a console setting.
But I'm not there.
I'm actually on my tablet.
So I can actually--
MALE SPEAKER: But you get to
mess around with the game.
DANIEL: That's right.
Well because I'm good friends
with these guys, you know--
MALE SPEAKER: Not for long.
DANIEL: Yeah, not for long.
I have angst with this
guy over here.
So I'm actually going to mess
with their game by interacting
with their game world and
putting a mine right there,
where that guy can--
oh look, he hit my mine.
Oh, look at that.
Sorry guy.
He didn't die quite
though, yet.
So maybe I'll throw
a missile on him.
MALE SPEAKER: So you could
choose to mess around with the
Red or Blue team.
I mean, you're in
control here.
DANIEL:Totally.
A malevolent or a benevolent
spirit, depending on how you
feel in this particular game.
This is a social game
experiment, really.
Since we were doing a prototype
build just purely
for research and design and
building a new technology.
We experimented with the idea of
a second screen smart glass
controller to basically jump in
the game wherever you are.
MALE SPEAKER: And you could also
use your mobile device,
your Android device as well.
DANIEL: Yes, you
certainly can.
You can use the new Nexus 7
they came out with today.
Totally.
You can come up here and scan
these QR codes we have on the
wall and jump right into in
this game that's playing.
MALE SPEAKER: Now what's the
future of this technology?
Have you already thought about
some other iterations of this
kind of third party interaction
with a game like this.
DANIEL: For sure.
A technology like this, fully
built out and then realized by
a full game team with a vision,
could produce a design
that hits you perfectly
wherever you are.
So you can be on your phone,
with your couple second
Facebook checking type
experience that's super fast.
You could be on the two hour
console experience.
You could be on the 10 minute
more tablet-y experience.
And each one of those would
be fed to you differently.
To the same technology, but in
a different stream, different
data that you need based
on where you are.
And you as the user
don't care.
You just want to play your
game in different ways
wherever you have the time
and can do that.
MALE SPEAKER: Now without giving
away the keys to the
kingdom, any sort of tips or
learnings from this for other
developers curious on doing
a similar thing?
DANIEL: Well one of the most
interesting things is that
your JavaScript web programmers
and your C++ and C
game engine programmers
tend to be
different breed of people.
And they don't live
in the same world.
And I guess we need to grow a
new world of community where
they like to play in the same
place with the same tools in
the same kind of--
[FEEDBACK]
MALE SPEAKER: We've got some
serious action going on here.
All right, we're going
to finish up.
If you can maybe show us a quick
demo again of what's
going on here.
DANIEL: Sure.
One last thing.
Now that I've been so mean,
I'm actually going to help
heal one of these guys by
dropping him a crate.
Get that crate!
There you go.
He's healed.
So, easy.
Easy to just influence a game.
MALE SPEAKER: So you
could be violent or
provide some first aid.
DANIEL: One of things we did
with this game was that we
made it super difficult to win
unless you have people in the
crowd that are on your side.
So it is in their best
interest to--
MALE SPEAKER: So
we'll encourage
folks to drop by later.
DANIEL: --to come
by and help out.
MALE SPEAKER: Daniel,
thank you so much.
DANIEL: Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: We appreciate
your malevolence.
DANIEL: Appreciate it, thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: OK we're joined
now by Jayme from the Chrome
team to talk about a project
that's redefining what it
means to have a jam session.
And I don't think I'm
overstating that.
Because this is absolutely
amazing.
So walk me through what this is
called and how people can
interact with these
instruments from
anywhere in the world.
JAYME: Sure.
So at I/O today we're giving
a demonstration of Web Lab,
which is a series of physical
installations housed at the
London Science Museum, and that
could be controlled by
anyone anywhere in the world
through their browser in an
immersive HTML5 experience.
Now one of those installations
is what
we're calling The Orchestra.
And it explores the theme of
how the web has now enabled
people from all over the world
to come together and make
things in ways that were
never before possible.
MALE SPEAKER: In this
case we're talking
about making music.
JAYME: So for music, what we've
done is created eight
robotic mechanical musical
instruments that are housed in
London Science Museum.
And you can come to
chromeweblab.com and take
control of those instruments
and make music with people
from all over the world in a
three minute jam session.
MALE SPEAKER: All right, this
is a fascinating demo, we
should say.
This is absolutely live
in London right now.
This is set up.
This is no trickery,
no pre-anything.
JAYME: No, no.
Not at all.
So it's coming up to 5
o'clock in the London
Science Museum now.
And if we go into the
experiment, we can get a live
video and audio stream
directly from there.
So we'll just give
it a sec to load.
MALE SPEAKER: And just so people
can know more, where
can they go to find out
information on this?
JAYME: Sure.
So at the moment, this
is just an exclusive
developer preview at IO.
You can go to chromeweblab.com
to watch the teaser trailer.
We're going to be launching in
beta later in the summer and
then coming out of beta once
we've got feedback, both
online and in the museum,
later in the year.
MALE SPEAKER: Or beta
for those of us on
this side of the pond.
JAYME:That's right.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So walk us through this.
It's really cool.
JAYME: Sure.
So once you've chosen to play
the museum instruments, you
have a choice of different
instruments to play from.
You can already hear that
there are a couple of
instruments being played
by people.
Let's say the vibraphone.
That's my favorite instrument.
So, it's just loading up the
video and audio here.
And we'll join the queue.
MALE SPEAKER: So if you want to
be a participant in this,
there's a queue for
each instrument.
You get a set amount of
time to participate--
JAYME: That's right.
There's a queue.
And each person has a
three-minute jam session.
So there aren't huge backlogs.
While you wait, you can still
go and play with any of the
other experiments
within Web Lab.
But we're already straight in.
So let's go for it.
MALE SPEAKER: So folks
who are at the museum
are seeing this happen.
Can they control some of these
instruments as well?
JAYME: That's right.
So there are eight instruments
in total.
During museum opening hours,
four are controlled by people
in the museum.
And four are controlled
by people online.
The other cool thing about
this project is that the
science museum is letting it run
for 24 hours a day, seven
days a year, for a whole year.
And so, at nighttime, all eight
instruments will be
handed over to online users.
MALE SPEAKER: Which will be
amazing to see this all
happening in the middle
of the night.
JAYME: Yeah, it's a real
night-at-the-museum type
experience.
MALE SPEAKER: All right, so
go ahead and play this
vibraphone for us.
JAYME: Yeah.
So here we have a sequencer.
You can see I'm the
pink colors.
The purple and blue dots are
other instruments being played
by people from around
the world.
So we're here in Moscone
in San Francisco.
MALE SPEAKER: And there it is.
It's playing--
JAYME: This is the live video
and audio coming through.
There's some clever stuff going
on with Web Sockets and
Node.js to make sure that all
the clients are synced.
And that the jam you're having
with someone in Brazil or
someone in New York is exactly
the same as what you're
hearing wherever
you're playing.
MALE SPEAKER: This
is super cool.
And just quickly, when
is it available for
everyone to try it out?
JAYME: So from later in the
summer, we're going to be
going into beta.
And go to chromeweblab.com and
follow Chrome's G+ page to be
the first to know when
it will launch.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
This is awesome stuff.
Jayme, thank you so much
for this tour.
Appreciate it.
JAYME: Thank you.
Cheers.
MALE SPEAKER: Moving
on to mobile now.
And for fans of Chrome, you
know that the Chrome
Experiments for desktop has
been around for awhile.
But the mobile experiments
is very recent.
We're joined by Boris, who is a
developer-advocate at Google.
Tell me a little bit about
Mobile Experiments.
Why it was created, and
how people can use it?
BORIS: Right.
So we launched this project for
the launch of Chrome for
Android stable, which happened
just yesterday.
And basically, all the
experiments are available on
chromeexperiments.com.
And if you're on a mobile
device, you'll get redirected
to the mobile version.
So here I have the mobile
version of the Chrome
Experiments on my phone.
And the phone is being mirrored
to this large display
here, so that you can
all see what's
happening on the screen.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
So anyone who wants to go and
get some inspiration can go to
the Chrome Experiments site.
BORIS: Exactly.
So Chrome Experiments initially
launched as a
community thing.
So a lot of people just have
been creating these great
visualizations and other
interactive animations, and
submitting them to Chrome
Experiments for other people
to get inspired and
submit their own.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So walk us through the
first one you've
got for mobile here.
BORIS: Sure.
So this is a multi-touch toy.
Of course on mobile, things are
a little bit different.
We have touch input, slightly
slower CPUs.
So a lot of these things
need to be done on GPU.
And a lot of interesting-ness
comes from multi-touch
interaction.
So here you can see,
as I move my finger
around on the screen--
MALE SPEAKER: That's really
cool with just one finger.
BORIS: Just one finger.
MALE SPEAKER: And can you pull
it up just a little bit?
And we can see you've got more
than one finger on there.
BORIS: Let me switch
modes as well.
I'll switch it to Galaxy.
So here you can see--
oops, sorry, that
must have been Bubbles.
I'll switch it to Galaxy.
And you can see the star
moving around.
Now, if I do multiple
fingers, three
fingers, even four fingers--
and this can track up to 10 or
so touch points at once.
MALE SPEAKER: Now can you talk
to me about some of the
technology involved with this?
BORIS: Sure.
So this is all being rendered
on a large Canvas element.
Canvas is a standard
HTML5 technology.
And generally, Chrome for
Android supports many of the
same HTML5 technologies
that Chrome does.
So here you can see, it's very
smooth, very responsive.
This is due to hardware
acceleration.
So, pretty neat stuff.
MALE SPEAKER: Very cool.
Let's move on to the next one,
which is a way to spice up
menu selections, which is part
of so many different apps.
But they can look staid and not
really that interesting.
And so, there's a new one here
that could provide some cool--
BORIS: This is a totally new
take on scrolling lists.
So let me go back to the Chrome
Experiments site.
And here.
You can visit this site as well
on your mobile device.
MALE SPEAKER: Again,
it's brand new.
So there are just a handful
of them there now.
But more to come, obviously.
BORIS: I think there's
about eight.
But we're going to open
this up for external
developers to submit.
So this is the list experiment
that we talked about.
And you can see here, what looks
like a regular touch
list comes to life when
I start scrolling.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, nice.
BORIS: So these little things
slide into place.
And this is all done with
CSS-3 animations and
transitions.
MALE SPEAKER: Nice.
So we don't have
much time left.
So I'd love to get to the
last example, if we
can, which is a game.
Which is very, very popular for
folks on mobile devices.
But in this case, it taps into
what we were talking about
earlier, with that multi-touch
ability.
BORIS: Exactly.
So the last one I'll show
is called Finger Forest.
And it is a side scroller, but
again it uses touch for input.
MALE SPEAKER: So they created
a little game here to
illustrate it.
BORIS: It's a little game.
So basically, it's a forest.
And the forest has acorns
and squirrels in it.
And you're the squirrel.
And let me just show this
on a different device.
So you're the squirrel.
And the idea is to bring the
squirrel to the acorn, and
make it do a happy dance.
So I'll just draw a line here.
MALE SPEAKER: All about
the happy dance.
BORIS: Definitely.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh no, Boris!
BORIS: So I seem to have
failed that one.
But if you succeed, eventually
you get to levels where you
have multiple squirrels
and multiple acorns.
And you have to solve
the puzzle.
And the trick is, you need to
keep your finger down on the
screen for the whole time.
Otherwise it crashes.
So it's a pretty simple
little game.
And what this uses-- it actually
technologically is
quite interesting.
Because it has multiple
canvases layered
on top of one another.
MALE SPEAKER: And here
you could use the
two fingers as well.
BORIS: And here we're getting
into two fingers.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
very cool.
Boris, thank you so much
for this demo.
The point is inspiration for
folks who are developing on
the mobile platform, right?
Thank you so much.
BORIS: My pleasure.
Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: And we finish up
our visit to the Chrome area
with Ido, who's going to do an
un-boxing of the Chromebox.
Which has been a sort of
replacement for the desktop.
And you're going to do it and
get it all set up here in
under two minutes.
Is that right?
IDO: Exactly.
MALE SPEAKER: Ready
IDO: You taking the time?
MALE SPEAKER: Go!
IDO: So first here,
I just open it.
It's packed real nice.
Put it aside.
First and foremost, just
put the electric in.
And then some Internet
connection.
MALE SPEAKER: Still got the
plastic wrap on it?
IDO: Oh yeah, that's fine.
I'll just clear it if we want.
MALE SPEAKER: You've got
all the connectors.
And tell me a little
bit about the specs
that's inside the Chromebox.
IDO: So, it's got
a very nice CPU.
It runs much faster than
it used to be.
And basically, this device
is replacing the desktop.
You're getting a very
easy installation.
If I'm [INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: And much
smaller, obviously.
IDO: Much smaller.
The design is really sleek.
And you'll see that now
it's booting up.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
That is under 30 seconds.
IDO: Yeah, and now actually
we could set it.
So it's really, really a smooth
and a nice experience
to set it up.
And it's already checking
the updates.
It will download, now,
the latest software.
And it's a very, very
powerful device.
I strongly recommend
it to users.
MALE SPEAKER: Now you're a
developer-advocate at Google.
What's the response been on the
Chromebox which has been
out for a few months or so?
IDO: Oh, it was very,
very great response.
We got lots of great feedback
that we are listening to.
And then we're going to
improve it over time.
And just like in Chrome, every
six weeks we're getting a new
version in it, which is
extremely important.
Because then you have the
speed, simplicity, and
security all baked in and
getting proven over time.
So unlike other systems, which
over time you need to take
care of them, this is actually
getting better over time.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So the Chromebox we have.
Of course Chromebooks, people
know about already, too.
What's the developer response
been between the two of them,
in terms of being able to do--
IDO: Oh, amazingly warm.
Actually on Chromebooks, we have
this huge battery life.
So you could literally go and
work with it for a full day.
And the battery is very nice.
The trackpad is amazingly
good.
And it's a very, very
nice device.
We mostly look at it as a
producing-content device.
So the keyboard is very nice.
If you need to write
long essays, that's
the device for you.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so are we
almost-- we're almost set up
here, right?
IDO: Oh, yeah, I could
just login.
MALE SPEAKER: So it's very
similar to a Chromebook
experience.
You use your Google account.
IDO: And once I'm in,
we have the sync.
So everything that I worked on,
on other machines would be
synced in automatically.
So the exact point that I left
my desktop, it's right here.
We could take a photo, just
for the first time.
I could actually
take my photo.
It just took it from my G+.
And at first we have this
initialize screen to show you
what's going on.
And it's updating--
MALE SPEAKER: And this
is actually bringing
in all of your tabs?
IDO: Everything.
All my extensions.
Everything that makes
me more productive.
And I am good and up to run.
MALE SPEAKER: I mean, obviously
it took a very, very
short amount of time.
And that's really the purpose
of this, is to-- of course
it's a great platform
for developers.
But it's such a seamless and
easy experience to just boot
up and be able to be online.
IDO: Absolutely.
And actually in Chromebook,
it will boot up in
less than six seconds.
Actually much faster,
most of the time.
MALE SPEAKER: Six seconds?
IDO: Six seconds.
From offline.
So if you are just in sleeping
mode, it's immediate.
And if you are offline, it's
probably six, maybe less.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
IDO: It's very impressive.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
fantastic.
You can't get much faster.
Well, I suppose you can
get faster than that.
IDO: Yeah.
I mean, it's extremely fast.
And we did that because in
that case, less is more.
So you're getting less
headaches, less things that
you don't really need in
use day in, day out.
And this actually great OS is
built for people that are
spending the vast majority
of their time on the web.
Which is lots of us.
MALE SPEAKER: Which is
pretty much all of
us these days, right?
IDO: Exactly.
So in that mind, this was the
main goal to achieve.
And I think it's working
very, very nicely.
MALE SPEAKER: All right, Ido.
Thank you so much for
that demonstration.
IDO: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: That
was fantastic.
Stay tuned for lots more
here at I/O Live.